apparently America is now post
post-racial that was quick
a new poll reveals Americans are bracing
for our summer of racial disturbances
across the country according to NBC News
in The Wall Street Journal
96 percent of adults surveyed believe
this year's racial unrest is symptomatic
of broader national problems but African
Americans and whites are deeply divided
about why the urban violence is
occurring 60 percent of blacks said the
violence was the result of long-standing
frustrations about police mistreatment
of African Americans while 27 percent of
blacks claimed the disturbances were an
excuse to engage in looting and violence
white respondents had an almost polar
opposite response 58% said the violence
was an excuse to loot while only 32
percent claimed the events were because
of long-standing frustrations with the
police
all right so clearly the most
interesting part of that is the end that
basically white and black people are
reviewing what's going on in the country
are now completely in Reverse
now you too are white am i correct which
is pretty much the worst thing there is
to this is three white people there is
nothing worse than this
so let's three white people talk about
at least four gay right at least three
only that's the only saving grace I'm
still taking my privilege like all the
time but like I at least have that going
so that will put you in the most special
yes
so as three white gay people with a
little bit of privilege and some of its
check there's something like that did
you think that after six years of Obama
being president that race relations
would seemingly be worse than they were
six years ago or are they not worse and
it's just some kind of media construct
or something like that I mean I think
did I think that they would be worse
after Obama was president I mean I think
that what would happen was is that it
would be talked about more like the
concept of race and racial improvement
because I think a lot of people put high
hopes in Obama changing the perspective
of how people were perceived racially
and I don't know if that happened I
think that now more discussion is being
had and people are kind of enraged
coming out in the public and it's being
heightened now but I don't know this
this whole thing first of all the fact
that 60% of black people are saying that
this is why we're pissed off and white
people are saying this isn't why you're
mad you know it's like wait a minute no
they just said that's why they're mad
right like white people don't get to
tell black man what they can be mad
actually that's all though they that way
for entire history yeah you know not
that I defend Fox News often but you
know every now and again there'll be a
black person on Fox News and people will
be like oh that's just a token black
person but you know defending whatever
but Who am I to tell any black person
what right they think whether I agree
with them or not sure I know I'm just
not shocked that white people miss the
point there do you think race relations
are actually worse they're like it seems
I don't know there's no words but I
think the people were like are
emboldened in a way to kind of like
speak out about the injustice as they
see in a way they were before which is a
great thing and because of that they're
a lot of scared racist people who like
are kind of nervous and sort of saying
the optical in the opposite direction so
they become more not actively racist but
like more outspoken in their you know
antic wouldn't believe it kind of serves
it serves the other thing you know yeah
it seems to me that just there are
always going to be a certain amount of
racist people but as long as they keep
that stuff private and aren't trying to
legislate on it or whatever make it
public then I guess it's okay like
you're allowed to wouldn't that be an
even if it were like no part of the
system yeah but they are you right yeah
what do we do to make some of this stuff
better I mean you're talking about it's
good right it's in the news now so
that's good and it's good to see that
minorities are feeling empowered that
they can do it but like what are we
actually I mean the root of the issue
has to be addressed here and and I don't
even know if we know what that is
people need to be hurt like actually sit
down and listen to why these people are
feeling so frustrated I mean the fact
that and also I feel like the media is
taking a huge card in this because you
know you're seeing the riots you're
seeing the looting and that's kind of
all you're seeing you're not
hearing the reasons behind you're not
into not a lot of people that are
looting are being interviewed right and
and you're just seeing this rage and
being removed from it even maybe in
California which is a liberal state
you're still seeing this you know really
fueled emotionally fueled response and
you're not really knowing what's behind
it or what's really going on and I on
the same token if you were to watch you
know I'm sorry but I've been living in
San Francisco now I was walking around
after the Giants won and similar
situations were happening and that was
over them winning the World Series right
and white people were burning cars but
it was it for some reason it wasn't
viewed with the same type of you know
shock and dismay yeah how much so as a
guy in the media how much this is
actually cuz people say this all the
time like if the media is only showing
the writing but I don't necessarily
think that the media has a narrative as
much as the media shows what will be
clicked on right if someone that burning
a car or has a bat and they're bashing a
police car yeah the media is going to
show that like I don't think the media
people like to think it's like a
conspiracy like the media sits down like
well but I think it's just they will go
to where well you can you can look to
BuzzFeed calm for more well-rounded but
I think that there are there is a sense
like people cover the riots on the
protesting that happens before the rise
they wait for my dramatic to happen it
doesn't look as good for the protesters
because you're not you're right can
you're not hearing their side of it
you're not of seeing the peaceful
protests that that sometimes erupt in
violence but you're focusing only on
like the the burning of cars right but
isn't that just the nature of what
people watch like we're doing this on
YouTube I know what people click on if
we talk about sex or beheadings they
literally get millions of views and if
we talk about political stuff again I
like my mug on fire if you guys smash
her with them that would not be posted
on YouTube like yes people will click on
that now and people are interested in
seeing that but is that because we don't
have a strong voice that is speaking out
and really pulling us in like I'm sorry
but like Martin Luther King we were all
you know and I mean not me personally
because I wasn't alive but you know
everybody was really just wanted to
watch wanted to be part and it was not
so much as words that were pulling
people in and I think we have a really
strong lack in that right now yeah do we
just need better leaders in general
because I would go on that like yeah
better I think yeah why not set our
leaders leaders where are you we need
better leaders all around anyway what do
you guys think our race relations worse
are they better is the media to blame is
the media getting together and secretly
talking about you and plotting how do
you live your life let us know in the
comments right